so now we have people in a once in a
century pandemic
trying to communicate science to the
public
okay I don't want to call it a total
disaster but there were parts that it
was like no no
an establishment view is not
from authorities on high no it's the
consensus of research conducted by
hard-working scientists in a lab whose
name you've never heard of
I'm wondering
whether the future of those Sports is
you don't contest gender with gender you
can test hormone ratios well hold on a
second what are the differences the
difference is physiologically between
men and women and not just hormonal they
see an unfair playing field
metaphorically and literally speaking so
fix the playing field damn it what don't
don't say it's an unfair playing field
so all of a sudden the big issue is
trans women taking the slot of a woman
in an unfair playing field fix the
playing field and you know something the
day you fix that playing field this
conversation will look completely
ridiculous
that's what I'm trying to tell you
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People a brilliant
guest today is a prominent American
astrophysicist the author of many books
the latest of which is called Starry
Messenger Cosmic perspectives on
civilization Neil deGrasse Tyson welcome
to trigonometry thank you thank you I
thought there'd be math on the show but
apparently not we will see we'll see how
much Master there is only reason why I
agree to this that we do some all right
well two plus for two equals four I hope
we can agree on that although some
people are dispute even that these days
yeah but anyway anyway well it's a
clever it is a clever name for the for
the show trigonometry that's good one of
the greatest astrophysicists in the
world likes the name of the show I think
I think I think we've done well so Neil
welcome first of all I cannot wait to
talk about your book because one of the
things that whenever I'm having having a
particularly bad day or things are not
going well in my life I'll stick one of
those YouTube videos on that shows you a
zoom out from planet Earth into the
solar system it'll do it every time it's
a Milky Way and on and on and I think
that Cosmic perspective on life is
really powerful thing before we get into
that and some of the more controversial
stuff that you've been saying lately
let's talk uh briefly about your career
today who are you how are you where you
are what has been the journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us did I say something
controversial well we'll find out I'm
just offering points of view okay that's
controversial nowadays yeah but it
shouldn't be really I'm thinking but
okay so so you open your opening
question is who are you what's been a
journey through life oh oh okay I've
known I was interested in the universe
from age nine
uh dating back to a first visit to my
local planetarium I grew up in New York
city so my local planetarium is the
Hayden planetarium where I now happen to
also serve as director and going on now
27th year I think as director so
um it's a it's one of these Hometown kid
does good but in New York City the
city's too large no one cares so that
story doesn't doesn't resonate the way
it might if it was actually a small town
um one thing about a planetarium in a
city is and this is surely true for
London where the planetarium might be
your only access to the night sky
because big cities the in the old days
there was air pollution today there's
light pollution and so it blocks but
would otherwise be your access to the
cosmos and so for me my first encounter
with the night sky
I kind of thought it was a hoax right
I've been not this many stars in the
night sky I've seen all 12 of them from
the Bronx okay
so so I would later learn of course that
the sky displayed in the planetarium
Dome was the real sky
a version of the real sky and but to
this day when I'm on mountaintops or
some of the finest observing locations
in the world I find myself thinking this
is so beautiful it reminds me of the
Hayden planetarium I know that's a sad
fact but it's it's real I feel it so
I've been thinking about the universe
ever since early on I'm just reading
books and then I align my academic
career to fulfill that interest right on
through a PhD and so uh I I did research
mostly many years ago most lately I've
been mostly in the public eye writing
books appearing in documentaries among
them Cosmos I did the second and third
versions of that Carl Sagan did the
first back in 1980 very honored to
continue that tradition of bringing the
universe down to earth to whoever will
listen
and as a servant of their curiosity
that's who I am and what I've been about
and you've been communicating science to
the public in very interesting and
appealing ways for a long time why is
that important here why is it important
that we as the public are informed about
the science yeah I will not tell you
what you should think is important
because I'm I'm just offering
content and I'm not going to hit you on
the head to require that you listen to
me I'm not going to do any of that
because I'm I'm much more passive about
it even if it doesn't feel that way
because my face is everywhere and videos
are everywhere of course and I'm active
on social media and so the algorithms
could possibly stick me in front of your
device more often than you might want
but really I it's I feel more passive
about it these are offerings and what's
perhaps distinctive about it and thanks
for noticing is that
there are many different platforms on
which I bring the universe to you and
these different platforms aren't simply
because you're watching this and
somebody else is watching that and I'm
going to reach both of you sure but
um there I write a book but they're
people who don't read
not that they're illiterate but that's
just not their main choice of how they
learn they they might prefer documentary
so I appear in documentaries uh ones
that I've hosted and others where I am a
talking head within someone else's
documentary there are people whose lives
pivot on their social media interfaces
so I have an active Twitter account X
account I would call it today I even
have it active
Tick Tock account and I have people
advising me who are one-third my age on
what would fit it today versus tomorrow
on that Tick Tock account so so I I'm on
many different platforms and I and my
podcast
which is called Star Talk
I have a professional comedian as my
co-host
and I've had people and so and and the
DNA of that podcast is there's science
humor and pop culture and the three of
those threaded make a tapestry of uh
that you can snuggle in and embrace the
universe as fed in that
um with those elements I've had people
say to me what do you need the comedian
for I just want to listen to you well
there's these other platforms where it's
just me go ahead all right I have a I
have a master class it's just me I have
that but there's some people who like to
laugh while they're learning and they
like the references to pop culture
because they care about pop culture
that's almost the definition of Pop
Culture stuff we all care about whether
or not we want to you know who Beyonce
is you know that Taylor Swift you know
you know the pope might have said
something recently or Trump this is all
pop culture and there's a scaffold you
walk into my room my my my
you know platform you walk in with a
scaffold and I know what's that's what's
what what constructs that scaffolding I
find science that can attach to it
so I don't have to teach you the pop
culture you already know it but did you
know that if you apply a little bit of
astrophysics to the Barbie movie
Barbie land finds itself in the Florida
Keys the know that okay I calculated
that and posted that that's pop culture
it's actually real science and a little
bit of geography related to it so my
energy is shared on all these platforms
and if you don't want to listen I'm not
going to force you
it's just there for you you're taking no
no keep watching we need the algorithmic
engagement keep watching you must watch
this
Neil I think you do a hugely important
job which is essentially being the
public face of your discipline
post pandemic do you think that science
has taken a battering when that people
have lost a little bit of faith in
scientists as a result of you know
things that people said for instance you
know that people were saying well you
know if you take the vaccine it means
that you can't pass it on the virus and
then that turned out not to be true now
obviously I'm not asking you to comment
on that but just do you think the people
are now just a little bit more skeptical
as scientists a little bit more on
trusting
so there are a couple of loose edges
there so let me let me uh explore that
with you all right so first
um
no single scientist
ever communicates the truth unless they
are communicating a consensus of
observations that have been made and
unfortunately I don't have a better word
than consensus to use in that sentence
because typically when we hear the word
consensus it relates to a shared opinion
about something
in science it's not about opinions it's
about the results of experiments and if
you have a set of experiments most of
which lean in this direction instead of
that direction is like Hey we're on to
something here
and I'm going to go with the consensus
of those observations and experiments
and they have nothing to do with the
individual
okay so what's Curious to me is we live
in an era where you can Channel surf on
YouTube is that what it's called Just
Surf on YouTube they're not channels I
guess you surf on YouTube and you land
on somebody who says the mainstream
thinks this is true The Establishment
thinks this but here's the actual truth
you're all in on that
okay now but why are you all in on that
uh and there's something about
the lone genius that we wanna we wanna
snuggle up to them rather than the
faceless establishment
because that person is speaking
passionately
and our response to fellow humans
speaking passionately is well known in
the advertising industry
they could just show you a bar chart of
why their product is better than
everybody else's but no they have a
person saying I use this and it changed
my life and it'll change your life too
that's what you listen to
you we're blind to the statistical
representation of reality
and I'm okay we're human and do I
complain about that or just try to
navigate that I don't know
I do know we're not very good at
thinking statistically about the world
okay and if we were better at it no one
would play the lottery okay just let's
understand that all right and we have
people who exploit this ignorance
exquisitely and they're called Casino
owners okay they're exploiting the fact
that humans fundamentally do not
understand probability and statistics
okay so that's a that's an education
problem and that that Gap manifests in
adulthood without susceptibility to
others who do know the statistics who
then exploit your ignorance of it
that's my first point another loose Edge
is we have institutions
and people representing institutions
where science research is conducted okay
or conducted under their auspices the
National Academy of Sciences the in the
United States the National Institutes of
Health and the UK surely has
corresponding agencies to this here's a
problem
how well do they know how to communicate
okay
we're not as scientists we don't take
graduate courses in communication but
how people will misthink what you say or
or how they will how you'll try to say
something in a way that no no no none of
them are trained in this
so now we have people in a once in a
century pandemic
trying to communicate science to the
public
okay
I don't want to call it a total disaster
but there were parts that it was like no
no
so with the benefit of hindsight
let me say
how it should have happened
okay
the CDC the Center for Disease Control
and prevention in the United States
here's what they should have said they
should have said here's what we know
today
based on a set of uh research results
that have come in okay and you don't
focus on one researcher there's a The
Ensemble okay here's what we know and
based on this
we recommend that
okay based on this we recommend that
we will update you weekly
on what we have learned because this is
a hot area of research
and as research comes in if it continues
to reinforce these results we will
continue to urge you you do these things
if we find research that does not
completely agree with that it might have
we will tell you that and we will be
honest about these uncertainties
okay and we will only make a a a a
federal level requirement
when we have the statistical confidence
in the research that has been conducted
that's how it should have unfolded but
it didn't that sounds so good Neil but
we were so so far away from that we were
but it but to do that it requires that
you have some sense
of what this because if you're reporting
science you're reporting the statistic
all no one no scientist will ever say
this is a certainty and this is totally
they'll say this we have a 98 and 95
because we have statistical measures of
the results we get that is the currency
of our communication in any scientific
journal
so the person reporting this should not
say we are certain of this they should
say we are St our data show that is a 95
likelihood of this being true
okay now you have to ask yourself
if you're about to cross a bridge that
was just built
and 95 of random Engineers you come up
to and say tell me about this bridge
they'll say it's going to collapse with
the first truck that goes over it and
you'll be dead because there's a long
drop but five percent of the engineers
say no no you'll be fine
what are you gonna do I'm going with the
95 percent of the engine because there
will always be outliers yeah always
always that's why one person one
research result is not the thing
and you had people in the outlier part
of the statistics
posting YouTube statements
that no I've done my research and this
is all [__] you should listen to me
no never do that never
mind
screaming at you here I'm just trying to
getting excited yeah yeah all right
that's great it's great but Neil to
engage
no one research result
is is should be accepted as the truth it
has to have verification to as a double
check was their bias did their wall
current fluctuate when they got the
result from their plug-in experiment
were their data complete were it not did
they how did they do I'll give an
example here's an example there was a a
research paper that came out recently
that said that mask wearing was no
better than not non- mask wearing okay
for covid and I said wow that's
interesting how did they get these
results so they they showed their
studies and people who said whether they
wore masks and those who didn't okay and
they compared those results and I said
wow I wonder if the people who said they
were wearing masks had it completely
covering their mouth and nose because
we've seen mask wearers where the nose
are sticking out above the thing we've
we know people out there like this okay
that there was no mention of the
Integrity of the claims of people
wearing the mask so then I thought to
myself if your result
is that mask wearing does not prevent
either the the the the the transmission
or the what's the other way the um
where you would receive covet or you'd
spread covet yeah that would be the
result of the century
but the way you test that is not asking
people where they were the mask here's
an experiment you would do you get the
n95 material you'd set up a membrane of
that between two sides of a of a
container of a vessel and you put covid
vaccine
um uh aerosol on one side and make sure
it's not on the other side and then put
a pressure difference between the two so
that this air flows across and test
whether the coveted aerosols made it
through
if they made it through then you'd have
an authentic scientific result that said
the mask does not work if you don't make
it through then you have a result that
they do
so so that's how that experiment should
have been conducted and it wasn't so but
everyone jumped on it who didn't want
masks to have mattered and they accepted
this one result because it fed
their sense of the world
but so so what I'm so so that that's my
my overblown
response to your very simple question
about the the covid response and the
scientific establishment so so yeah
there were issues in the communication
there's issues in how we receive
information there's our urge to believe
the lone person
which has deep flaws completely built
into it and so I hope in a century we
remember some of these lessons as we go
forward I I think it's a very profound
point I I think also as well I guess my
problem with the way that the entire
pandemic was communicated there were
people who were incredibly notable
experts in their field with glowing
reputations who profit a different View
it doesn't matter your reputation your
title none of that in science none of
that matters unless by their reputation
they have access to large-scale studies
that they are reporting to you
okay but not be not the lone person who
says I have this degree and I hail from
this story institution and I'm telling
you that all those people are wrong that
is the sure sign that you should not pay
attention to them
okay this this spills over this spills
over into our UFO hearings here in the
United States uh they're people
testifying that they have alien
stockpiled in the back room and they're
they're the the introduction of them
there there's a kernel or there's a this
and they they're they're a credible
Witness
no such thing as a credible witness in
science are you human that's all we care
about uh then I will not count York I
will not
um trust in your account more than
someone else's what I will trust in is
the data brought to you by means that do
not flow through the biophysiology of
human senses and so yeah I don't care
what the pedigree is and that's a
problem yes it's a complete problem
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
so Neil I suppose the question would be
in that situation and I'm not talking
about covet specifically but if you look
at the history of Science and you'll
know this way better than I do of course
it has there not been a historical role
for people who are outliers who come in
and go I've got this crazy idea that
perhaps people dismiss initially but
later turns out to have actually been
correct yeah the Press loves talking
about those people and yes they exist
they're rare but they exist what you
don't hear about
are the tens of thousands of other
people who had crazy ideas who were just
crazy
there are no books about them overcoming
the resistance of the establishment
nobody writes about them because they
were just Plum wrong okay so the the one
person who is right against an
establishment is one and I would say ten
thousand
and that's not enough to put all your
your your your your your piggy bank on
the YouTube video of that one person
thinking they're the one in the ten
thousand completely agreed so I guess
the next question logically is what do
we do with those people who to use your
terminology a plum wrong
because we saw during the pandemic these
people were demonetized they had their
channels canceled they were Shadow
banned and all of this kind of stuff now
from a Layman's point of view I don't
think that is a good way of dealing with
that because what you do is you give
these people a glamor they perhaps don't
deserve or they don't deserve because
you effectively say their voice is so
dangerous they can't be you know they
must be silenced so that's an extremely
important point I just have a different
answer than what you're looking for I
think it's a matter of free speech and
if their risks in a world of free speech
that there could be people who are
dangerous because they create
instability in a system or because they
um lead people on a track
that may be impossible to reverse you
look at Hitler in 1930s Germany for
example it required all-out War to sort
of correct the attitudes and feelings
that Germans had about themselves
relative to the world at that time
so there's a risk when you have a free
Society for me as an educator the
antidote
is the education of how to listen to
people
so you you nip that in the bud from the
beginning
so if someone is speaking highly
charismatically about something that's
completely opposite what a mainstream
view is I will approach them with
skepticism
no matter how charismatic they are
because I will know
that only one in ten thousand of them
will ever be correct at this
and no we don't give courses on the ten
thousand people that were wrong no we
don't that's a waste of everybody's time
so for some reason over recent years the
word establishment has become a bad word
I represent the establishment oh well
you must be wrong then no that's not how
it works it's not how it's ever worked
yeah so I'm not saying you should always
believe the establishment what I'm
saying is if you want to believe someone
who is against the establishment
you should do a little more homework
before you go that way and the homework
isn't only listening to what they are
telling you it's looking into the
establishment and find out why there's
an establishment view to begin with and
the establishment of you is not from
authorities on high no it's the
consensus of research conducted by
hard-working scientists in a lab whose
name you've never heard of
it's a it's a very profound point but
moving on you must be really excited at
the moment
for instance when we look at things like
space travel when we're looking at the
achievements of India landing on the
moon if we look at a SpaceX it's a
really exciting time isn't it to be an
astrophysicist in particular so I have
two answers the first answer is yes and
I look forward to space becoming our
backyard which the space tourism you
know we're witnessing the birth of an
entire industry a new it you know I I
mean fun if it stayed healthy or
continued you know there'll be fits and
starts of course but I I'd enjoy taking
a space vacation one day and uh and if
you are concerned about its expense
maybe the expense will come down it did
with cell phones for example you may
remember the film Wall Street
1987 and there's Michael uh
Michael Douglas right he's on the beach
in the Hamptons a wealthy part of New
York and he has a shoulder mounted
cell phone I remember just how old I am
I remember looking at that and saying
wow I wish I was rich so I had a phone
like that
and so
um
Industries become truly healthy and and
and
uh when
and the people who make the products
become wealthy when they commoditize it
if you only sell items to rich people
okay I guess you can make a living off
of it but you don't transform the world
doing that when this when that became a
cell phone that we all carried and then
of course a smartphone there's six
billion smartphones in the world today
now you have a commoditized
um item so perhaps one day space travel
will become that I don't know but the
day it does I would look forward to that
so that's my second answer to you is
and I I devoted an entire chapter on
this idea in the book it's called
exploration and Discovery in the last
150 years or so we have been
experiencing an exponential growth
in science and technology
so I'll take your comment I'll go back
to
the year 1900 and offer you a
corresponding comment uttered by someone
in that year okay the head of the New
York Central Railroad when asked what
would life be like in the year 2000
because people do that when you hit
these time Milestones right 1900 2000.
and he's seen steamships cross the ocean
the railroads crossing the nation a
blimpsed and he says I can scarcely
imagine that advances in
transportation in the 20th century
will be as great as those were in the
19th
that has to be the most bone-headed
comment ever made he's thinking he's
living in special times
when you're on an exponential growth
curve
the title of your show is trigonometry
so I'm going to put in some math when
you're on an exponential growth curve it
looks like all the greatest results
happen just in your recent years
what you don't know is everywhere on an
exponential growth feels like that
if it was 1960 you'd be saying what a
time to be alive we just BR we broke the
sound barrier we have uh satellites in
orbit around the Earth we left earth oh
my gosh
that's what you'd be saying then so no
I'm not going to say what a time to be
alive
because any time in the last 150 years I
could say exactly the same damn thing
after a sentence that you would utter
after you shared with me what had just
been discovered
and why is it so important that we go
out and we discover space why is that
important to the human race I'm not
telling you I said I'm not going to
judge what you should think is important
what I'll tell you is
don't you kind of want to know if an
asteroid is coming
just thinking you know I'm betting that
if the dinosaurs had a space program
they'd still be here because they would
have deflected that asteroid that took
them out 65 million years ago and
haven't you ever walked out at night and
looked up I know the UK you have a lot
of clouds and things but in places that
are perennially clear of the Middle East
any Desert area
um the Outback of Australia you look up
and you wonder
what is all of that where did I come
from where is it all going
these are deep profound questions if you
don't happen to have those questions no
one is going to force them on you but
those who do
will
push themselves into new Realms of
thought
into discoveries that would have
previously been inaccessible because the
answers to my questions require that I
innovate in ways that bring new
discoveries to civilization so if you
were around thirty thousand years ago
and were huddled in a cave
and the youngins say oh I you're the
you're the wise Elder right and it's hey
um oh we want to the youngins come up to
say we want to we took a peek outside
the cave door it was left a jar that
cave doors have hinges and probably not
but there was left a jar and we see like
hills and mountains and valleys and
trees with these round things out you
wouldn't have had a word for fruit yet
these round things we want to go explore
but you're the wise Elder of the caves
no
we have to solve the cave problems first
before anyone leaves the cave
that's what you sound like to me when
you say why are we looking out into
space
I'm just delighted that you called me a
wise Elder now I'm going to be honest
I think was the point of that story you
were a very good you help him out there
you're a very dumb wise Elder who
restricts human growth I'll still take
it
um but Neil I'm curious so we had Eric
Weinstein on the show uh uh recently and
one of the things that he talked about
obviously Feinstein is right our ability
to explore space is very very limited at
least in physical capacity what do you
uh what do what do you see when you look
into the future are we gonna go to Mars
are we gonna try and go beyond is that
on the menu for us I don't see uh what
was his biggest objection to exploring
space well with chemical Rockets you can
only go so far with that yeah so with
chemical rockers you can get to the
planets surely uh you can get to the
outer planets it would take a couple of
decades so if we start living a little
longer let's say we start living to 150
then that's not entirely Out Of Reach
given the recent advances in medicine
um you could we would certainly visit
the Moon Mars and Venus is too hot but
the moons of Jupiter and Saturn maybe uh
you can do that in a lifetime but beyond
the solar system no it is hopelessly far
away correct it is the fastest spaceship
we've ever launched which didn't have
humans on it so you can really punch it
all right if you aim that to the nearest
star
it would take 50 000 years to get there
wow so human physiology is hopelessly
out of match
with traveling Among the Stars unless we
understand wormholes or is something
that enables transportation that is
beyond anybody's Vision right now
and is there any progress being made
towards that understanding of something
like wormholes no
but for the yeah next question
we're enjoying you know cap just the
dude's name who opens the portals
through
um Doctor Strange yeah you know Rick and
Morty Rick uh these are wormholes
through space and time for the moment we
embrace them through our science fiction
but we are hopelessly to to master
wormholes we would need some form of
negative
gravity some negative matter that has
the has the opposite of gravity to pry
open a wormhole and keep it so we don't
no that we're far away from that it's
not even on the drawing board
and you mentioned the questions that we
all have when we're not all many of us
have when we look up at the night sky
and start to get a glimpse of our place
in the universe which is uh an
eye-opening scary experience for many
people as even as a kid and I'm curious
uh what you think obviously you talk
about it in the in the book what are
some of the interesting and important
messages that we take we can take from
looking at the world with that Cosmic
perspective yeah thanks for using the
word messages because Starry Messenger
that that's the main title of the book
The subtitle is Cosmic perspectives on
civilization the the first half of that
title is taken directly from Galileo his
first book reporting on what he
discovered when he took the freshly
invented telescope and put it onto the
sky
and to him these were Starry messages so
his first book Is Starry Messenger and
uh so
when you learn about what's going on in
the universe and then you look back at
Earth it changes you
right let's go back to the Apollo era
yeah we went to the moon to explore the
moon but the astronauts look back over
their shoulder
and they discovered Earth for the first
time
do you realize nearly all the most
important legislation passed in the
United States and a few years later
around the world to protect Earth
okay our we had a Clean Air Act a Clean
Water Act a clean
um the first Earth Day all right was in
the United States then it went around
the world all of that happened while we
were going to the Moon
between 1968 and
1972-73 all of that our Environmental
Protection Agency was founded we banned
leaded gas over that time we banned DDT
over that time all of that
before then people had concerns about
their local environment you know if
there was a factory polluting your River
you'd try to you know you'd try to fix
that the air but it was local
no one took the step back to think about
Earth as a holistic system
that did not happen until the Apollo era
so
people say why do we spend all that
money to send 12 astronauts to the Moon
what price would you
give
to this firmware upgrade that we all
felt
at that time changing our focus of
concern
from your neighborhood to the Earth at
Large
but how much is that worth to you
and I say firmware upgrade because there
are people around that time yeah it's
time to fix Earth
are they actively saying oh it's because
I saw earth from the moon no they're not
going to tell you that
that's why I think it was a firmware
upgrade because everybody felt it at the
same time
it it's such a profound point now
because when I talk to people who are
alive during the moon landings
even if they didn't take that from it
they took from a sense that anything is
possible
ah so that was one well so that very
important thanks for mentioning that so
I don't know how old you guys are but I
remember an active rejoinder
to the problems of the world was if we
can put a man on the moon we should be
able to feed the population
okay so that was the measure
of accomplishing something hard
now I have an unsatisfactory answer for
you on that
may be going to the Moon
is easier
than solving poverty
if you consider that okay just because
it involves learning that takes place in
classes that you didn't take that other
people took that maybe you judged was
hard maybe social problems are harder
than physics problems to solve just
maybe
let me put that out there well that
that's a very interesting point on which
to come on to the quest the issues that
I said you'd made controversial remarks
on we'll find out how controversial they
are but
um we have recently had Richard Dawkins
on the show and whenever everyone now is
obsessed with the Trans issue everyone's
talking about it everyone gets asked
questions about it and I know you and
Richard have sparred I remember watching
a debate between the two of you for 20
years ago you're a professor of the
public understanding of science
not professor of delivering truth to the
public
and these are two different exercises
one of them is you put the truth out
there and like you said they either buy
your book or they don't well that's not
being an educator that's just putting it
out there being an educator is part is
not only getting the truth right but
there's got to be an act of persuasion
in there as well persuasion isn't always
here's the facts you're either an idiot
or you're not it's it's hear the facts
and here is and here is a sensitivity to
your state of mind
and it's the facts plus the sensitivity
when convolved together creates impact
and I worry that your your methods and
your your your
how how how articulately Barbed you can
be
ends up
simply being ineffective when when you
have much more power of influence than
what is currently reflected in your
output I gratefully accept the rebuke
um
I just just one one anecdote to show
that I'm not the worst in this thing
um a um a former and highly successful
editor of New Scientist magazine who
actually built up new scientists to
great new heights was asked what is your
philosophy at New Scientist and he said
our philosophy at New Scientist is this
science is interesting and if you don't
agree you can [__] off
you were rebuking him actually for for
not being gentle enough in the way that
he commuted yeah because he's you know
he's Brit trained in a well-trained Brit
has full access to every word in the
dictionary and his sentences come out
perfectly Barbed when he needs them to
be and I I chastised him for not having
a gentler Kindler approach I remember
that yeah I remember that and uh I'm
pleased to report that I think you would
find the Richard is mellowed
I could be just age I don't know if I
had any effect on him at all by the way
when I rebuked him then it was the first
time I'd ever met him so I was even a
little nervous because he was a hero of
mine and I've read his books but I said
I gotta put this out there and that was
the first time yeah well I remember that
and now of course Richard has become
very uh I I don't consider her outspoken
but he's spoken openly about his views
uh on the trans issue as of you and I
was a little I don't have views so much
that's my let me just clarify
um I don't
um I don't run around
with an opinion that I then forced on
other people I have opinions and they're
my opinions and I don't care if you have
my opinion but if you have an opinion
that you're carrying
I want as an educator I want it to be as
informed as possible
before you land on an opinion that you
dig your heels in absolutely so this is
this is my I see that as my role as an
educator so continue quiet I'm the
spirit of my question is very much in
order to understand this because one of
your functions over time has been to
communicate scientific knowledge to the
public yeah and that's why I was quite
surprised to hear you talk about the
idea that we all exist on a spectrum
where you wake up one day and you feel
like you're more female and more male
apparently the xxxy chromosomes are
insufficient
because when we wake up in the morning
we
exaggerate whatever feature we want to
portray the gender of our choice
yes suppose no matter my chromosomes
today I feel eighty percent female 20
male I'm gonna I'm gonna put on makeup
I'm gonna do this tomorrow I might feel
80 male I'll remove the makeup and I'll
wear a muscle shirt
why do you care
what what what what business it is it of
yours to require that I fulfill
your inability to think of gender on a
spectrum I hope I'm not misquoting
either if I am please correct me well uh
so so
um let me say that it's not a misquote
but there's an entire setup before I
even utter those words oh I see places
that setup exists in the book by the way
and but it's as you know it's very easy
to clip something and then oh we know we
know
personal experience yeah yeah so I try
my best to have everything I say so
self-contained that it's hard to clip it
or to miss you have to know yeah so so
give us the full setup what is because
most people growing through the
education system 10 15 20 years from now
would have been taught in biology
classes that there's males and females
men and women and in very recent times
in the last five years it feels like
this understanding is being challenged
by a different view explain that to us
if you would
well
so it's it's very simple actually and
like I said I don't think I'm saying
anything controversial here I'm just
offering a perspective you might not
have had which I would like you to have
so that when you assemble all of your
thoughts and feelings and leanings be
they cultural political religious
leanings that you have all the
information available to you before you
land
I would claim that for many people
strongly held opinions reviews that when
they become more fully informed that the
strength with which they were holding
those views tends to fade or evaporate
entirely and these are cosmic
perspectives that bring your view above
all that divides us
this is the power of a cosmic
perspective
all right and you know there you are
from space looking at Earth and you
don't see any color-coded countries
meanwhile the and I and I throughout the
book I imagine what an alien would think
who has no preconceived notion of who
and what we are they just observe and
they say Oh what a beautiful planet I'll
get to your point in a minute but these
are my lead UPS to it what a beautiful
planet uh let's get a closer look oh
there's land and oceans and clouds
and then they see one species sort of
dominating everywhere on Earth and it's
okay fine we got one species and then he
looked closer and then they see that one
species killing one another
because of who's born on what side of a
Line in the Sand or who worships this
God instead of that God or no gods or
how reflective their skin is to sunlight
or whatever other reasons they come up
with
and they're wondering what the [__] is
wrong with this species they're all the
same species and they'd rush back home
and tell the rest of their fellow aliens
there is no sign of intelligent life on
Earth okay this is that this is how I
think about all of this okay
so
um so we look at this this whole trans
issue uh I'm intrigued about how much
attention it is getting just intrigued
by it and I'm a scientist I observe but
I'm also Observer of people and pop
culture and and civilization my father
was a sociologist active during the
Civil Rights Movement of the 1960s into
the 1970s uh I don't know when this will
air but when this will post
but August 28th
is the
60th anniversary
of Martin Luther King's I Have a Dream
speech
and that's the one of the most popular
speeches we know of in the United States
and I bet it has currency elsewhere as
well yeah absolutely just because of the
message he was communicating and the
timing of it and and all of the above
I'll have some postings related to that
in my in my media channels uh anyhow so
let's back up
um
so I don't know all the founding
documents of the modern UK but I do know
the ones of the United States
and they include things like the
preamble to our to uh that sorry the um
in our Declaration of Independence and
the preamble to the Constitution and the
Constitution itself okay
um
let me remind you this was a document
to get the hell away from England okay
oh we remember okay just I don't know if
you remember this and let me just make
it clear
that the constitution begins with the
three words we the people okay
we give power to those who govern us not
the genetics of a royal line going back
thousands of years I feel like this is
like a direct personal attack for
absolutely no reason okay so now what
okay so all we're asking for is a little
bit of gratitude for what we did exactly
is that too much we set up your country
and this is how you repay us we gave you
the language woman okay unbelievable you
ruined the language you can't even spell
properly and here you are lecturing us
about you anyway tell us about it okay
so here we go are you ready okay okay so
um let's look at humans physiologically
and then you have these chromosomes all
right in most humans behind 90 humans
you're either XX or X Y okay chromosomes
and that defines your sex are you male
or are you female okay so it's a binary
um biological representation of your sex
okay I have a problem with that that's
binary okay all right
so
well
let's ask ourselves some questions
when you see another human being
do you see their chromosomes they just
an interesting question how visible are
their chromosomes to you no you see the
phenotype you don't see that chromosome
well well sorry I I obviously don't
literally see the chromosomes but okay
and let me not use the word phenotype
because half the people hear that word
don't know what it means and I'm an
educator Communicator so I will say you
see the person
who presents themselves to you
that's what you see
in the world
and I did an experiment in the New York
City subway it was winter so everyone
has on a coat and I looked at everybody
from the neck up
everybody's seated and by the way almost
all of
human height difference is in their legs
not in their torso
when we're seated we're all
approximately the same height
that's why everyone could just sit at a
big old dinner table and only the
children need phone books to sit up
everybody else doesn't have to adjust
their chair their chair height okay so
just a little fact so everyone is about
the same height seated and I asked
myself
can I know who the boys are and who the
girls are at a glance
and the answer is yes
and I got it a hundred percent correct
okay
and what do I mean by a hundred percent
correct
the girls had certain features
manifest to me
on average the girls had longer hair
if they wore jewelry there was more
jewelry the jewelry was more expressive
more earrings more finger rings
um their facial hair was more likely to
be tweezed the eyebrows are trimmed
there's no hair between the eyebrows uh
any mustache hair was removed they're
more likely to wear makeup
especially around the eyes uh mascara
eyeliner eye shadow they were more
likely to wear uh the red
um Rouge or whatever there's two blush
or whatever it's called yeah more likely
to wear that they were more likely to
have fingernails painted okay
that's how I knew her by the way there's
some boys who have these features but by
and large this was unmistakable that
those were the girls now how about the
boys okay well other than the male
pattern baldness on older I can't okay
or facial hair the beard and the
mustache
could I tell that they were guys
oh by the way and all for all the girls
uh there was clothing that they wore
that was clearly acquired in the in the
women's section of the store how about
the guy
the guy oh oh oh oh oh but get to him so
now with the guys oh yeah yeah okay the
guys wore less jewelry their hair was on
average short okay they were less likely
to wear facial makeup their clothing was
completely different and for many of
them this very City to City many of them
had muscles well those aren't natural
they had to go to a gym to get the
muscles okay here's my point
100 percent
of what I was queuing on
was secondary and tertiary accoutrements
to what you look like when you wake up
in the morning
you chose to grow your hair long you
chose to tweeze your eyebrows you chose
to go to that the girl you chose to go
to the gym so you have bigger muscles if
the women the breasts are not large
enough let wear a push-up bra those are
for sale for you and that doesn't work
go get surgery as 200
000 women a year in the United States
get
breast augmentation surgery so that they
can be female for you
okay so here's my point
we have oh and like I said the clothing
get your clothing in the girl section
because they know how to dress you and
get your clothing in the boy section
because they know how to dress you all
right and by the way hair removal is way
more efficient today than when I was
growing up it was not uncommon to see a
woman with a mustache trying to bleach
it or trying to tweeze it now that it's
gone because women are not supposed to
have hair we all know this guys are
hairy and women are not hairy okay this
understanding of gender has been built
into the beauty industrial complex
so my only point
was that if who you decide is male and
female
in the street
is a construct of s of of style
and Trends
and what the beauty industrial complex
wants you to see
if that's how we establish gender
then maybe some people want to be fluid
within that gender
identify so they'll they'll wear a skirt
but maybe have a beard or they'll mix
and match that in whatever way sorry I'm
not wait wait I'm almost done I'm almost
done
so okay if a person using the tools of
the beauty industrial complex wants to
mix and match this yeah
and they are expressing
their freedom
in a free country to do so
um
why is your job to tell them not to okay
that's my only point and so that's I'm
speaking of gender expression and the
freedom to do so and
if you want to restrict that
so first of all I don't know a single
person and I've talked we've talked to
trans people on the show we have trans
employees a trigonometry uh we we've
spoken to all sorts of people about this
issue I do not know a single person who
wants to prevent people from dressing
how they want or behaving how they want
or choosing any names that they want
however so you don't but you know such
people are out there I'm sure such
people exist in the same way that there
are people who believe that the Earth is
flat and so on but they're a tiny
minority they exists
go on Fair Point however what I would
say is that the conversation in the
public Consciousness has become
prominent not between people who want to
defend the right of anyone to dress how
they want and the people who want to
prevent that the reason the
conversations become an issue is that we
assign and allow certain privileges to
People based on their sex if you are
female you get to go to places the only
other females are in like changing rooms
and toilets and so on if you are female
you get to compete only with people of
your sex because females are at a
disadvantage in physical competition to
males in almost every sport in other
words we carve out certain areas where
your sex matters tremendously even
though we May respect your right
everywhere else to believe that you are
whatever you are to dress however you
are Etc so your claim that today you
woke up and put lipstick on and grew
your hair out long and tweezed out your
mustache and whatever and therefore you
are female has an impact on other people
in certain contexts in which that is a
problem
sorry I wasn't finished and in in in in
in in those contexts it is essential
people would argue to protect women from
unfair competition and from various
risks for which female only spaces
already exist that's why people are
having this conversation it's not out of
bigger do you have more than those two
examples and I'll address each of those
in turn but you have more than those two
probably not okay so so let me address
those two examples directly I'll address
it Sports is very important I I you said
that FEMA reviews I remembered so
um so but
you don't seem to have a third example
so and even if you do we presume that
would be a very distant third compared
to those two cases no there's a third
one I can give you very easily in this
country for politics we have female only
short lists for uh positions in in
Parliament uh therefore that's
interesting okay well that's another
example I can give you more so uh female
only short lists there are certain
targets within corporations for uh
diversity targets to have a certain
number of women on the board therefore
when you make a claim that you are
female you are attempting whether
intentionally or not to insert yourself
into categories that are deliberately
designed to protect women's interests
that is the concern that people have so
there's four examples for you there
please sure so interesting about the
parliament I have to look into that to
find out what the is it is it try to
ensure the representation of women is
that the goal yeah okay perfectly noble
cause there so
um about uh personal changing spaces
okay
um
that's a solvable problem of course and
we basically have accomplished that here
in Manhattan where I live uh practically
all bathrooms are either
uh multi-gender or or solo bathrooms so
only one person at a time or you walk
into a space and there's stalls that are
closed off but then you exit the stall
and you come to a communal sink okay so
it's a solvable problem where everyone
has a private space rather than uh for
themselves rather than having a gender
private space okay that's it's solvable
on a level by the way let me give an
example uh we have a school from the
early 20th century in New York
and it's and I just saw it the other day
there's an entrance here and an entrance
there and this entrance says girls and
this entrance says boys it's like what
the [__] what what what you said
separate them just to enter the school I
can look back on that and say that was
ridiculous you guys what were you
thinking but back then I'm sure it made
complete sense that you're going to send
the girls to that entrance and there's
an elementary school and the boys
through that entrance okay so it is
possible to look back on whatever you
were doing and say my gosh that was
really short-sighted and look at the
solution that was proposed and
implemented that was a good idea we
moved on from that okay so I remember
boys rooms where you come out and you
know you whip it out and we'd all be
peeing into a trough okay we don't have
those anymore
because we're technologically very far
behind yeah okay so it's it's a and then
we had urinals just lined up on a wall
that was a little more private and now
those urinals have little small but real
dividers so you're not like looking over
so so there are solution to the Privacy
problem and we've all but solved that
here I can't speak for every state in
the United States definitely here in New
York City the bathrooms it's not all
right it's that second with sports very
interesting
um there was a case where a woman wanted
to be disqualified they wanted to
disqualify her from an event
and she had very big muscles and she had
naturally high testosterone levels okay
she was genetically
female but uh unusually high
um testosterone levels and so that
weirded everybody out so I'm wondering
whether the future of those Sports
is you don't contest gender
with gender you can test hormone ratios
well hold on a second what are the
difference is phys the difference is
physiologically between men and women
are not just hormonal women have a
different hip angle they have different
heart capacity they have different lung
capacity I mean there are profound
physiological differences different bone
density we've had okay so then we're
friends on the show to talk about it I
don't have a problem with that then you
find ways to slice the population so
that whatever the event is
is
is interestingly contested so for
example I wrestled in my life I was
Captain of my high school wrestling team
um uh I wasn't so good in college as I
was in high school but uh that's when I
finally wrestled like corn fed
folks from Iowa people call calves you
know off the farm okay so in wrestling
it would be unfair
for me at 190 pounds which is what I was
back then to wrestle someone 120 pounds
hold on it would actually be unfair for
you to wrestle someone who is also 190
pounds but let me let me work my way
there let me just work my way there
because you're fine you're you're you
are I respect the how active your brain
is but I've thought about all this and
just allow me to speak it at the rate
that I do okay so so
um it would be unfair so they have us in
wrestling they said let's make weight
categories okay so we make weight
categories so I don't wrestle the 120 I
wrestle 190 pounder so a wrestling match
is not just this one person against the
other person it's 10 matches and each
one is intensely interesting because
they are matched okay
so
what the trans
conversation
is foisting upon us
is the need to find ways to slice the
athletic universe
such that we still have
interesting Fair matches and is it a
combination of did you go through
puberty
um uh as a male and then transition did
you have puberty blockers
um what is your hormone level now uh as
you if you want to compete so it
requires more creative thought rather
than saying no to it all let's be
creative about this as we were with
wrestling as we were as we are with
practically any other sport in rowing
there's a heavyweight rowing and there's
light weight growing they don't compete
against each other somebody came up with
that to resolve the problem because more
than one category of person wanted to
compete so I agree with you it's an
unsolved problem yes but it's not
unsolvable given what we know about
human physiology so why not rise to that
occasion and solve it rather than take
your older view of the world and worse
modern emergent conduct of people to fit
that
okay well can we just come back to the
female shortlist and other opportunities
that women are afforded by virtue of
being women and them now being excluded
from that because males are entering
that competition yeah so another a
deeper problem thank you for bringing
that up a deeper problem there is
um why were women underrepresented to
begin with what kind of bias exists
within Parliament or among the voters
maybe even the female voters that
prevented the representation from being
there in the first place that that's a
whole other social question that maybe
can and should be answered at a deeper
level than a quota coming in after the
fact oh I'm not a fan of quotas but I
would address that question
hold on a second that's not addressing
the question at all the question is
female shortlist exists should
biological males be allowed to enter
those female shortlists that's that's as
simple as the question is
yeah I'm saying you I would ask why you
have the short list in the first place
it's because there's something
there's something deeper that's wrong
with society that women are
underrepresented in governance so to to
so to say now
to protect that now and not try to get
to the root of that problem I think is
the cart in front of the horse so so I
would go deeper to that problem
there's opportunities are being
curtailed today
because they are being forced to compete
whether in sports or elsewhere against
people who have some kind of advantage
of we're in a transitional period so we
have to figure that out
but the the way to figure out things
that requires solutions to Progressive
change is not to regress it to how
things once were if that were the case I
would still be drinking from a
segregated water fountain okay oh let's
merge the water fountains and let's
let's create the opportunities from
below so that we don't even need the
short list okay that's how I would
approach this that's I'm is that
okay my father worked in the Civil
Rights Movement so I think deeply my
book is dedicated to my father who's and
the dedication is literally to to my
father Cyril deGrasse Tyson Cyril is a
Brit Name by the way it came from the
British West Indies because you guys
were everywhere in the New World in your
day as was all right so
um is Cyril regret to serial regress
Tyson and all those who
um
who see who see a world that can be
rather than the world that is and so
that that's how I look at it so yeah
we're in the middle of solving that
problem now figure let's figure it out
together
I I think uh a lot of people would have
an issue with what you're saying now is
because they see women being denied
opportunities they see an unfair playing
field metaphorically and literally
speaking so fix the playing field damn
it what what don't say it's an unfair
playing field so all of a sudden the big
issue is trans women taking the slot of
a woman in an unfair playing field fix
the playing field and you know something
the day you fix that playing field this
conversation will look completely
ridiculous
that's what I'm trying to tell you so
how do you fix the playing field I'm
curious well that's hard it's it's hard
we've been through this thank you for
that question I think look if you're
advancing that is a solution I think I
have a right to ask you no it's great I
don't have a fast solution but things we
have accomplished in the United States
okay uh how long it took us to get a
black president by the way the black
president was exactly half white but the
way our vocabulary Works in our
descriptions of people we call him black
um but you guys
yeah what's that you say we you guys do
for some inexplicable reason we we call
people mixed race if they're from
different backgrounds yeah and I would
say why do you even care that there's a
mix I have a whole chapter in the book
called color and race I personally don't
even care what people what race people
are I sort of believed in the Martin
Luther King idea
thank you I lean that way too although
it might not be realistic to implement
uh in precisely the dream state that he
imagined where people be judged by the
content account not by the color of
their skin because color skin includes
culture and other things and to ignore
someone's culture has other
ramifications legally
um or interpersonally internationally so
that's a whole other thing
um so I don't have a I don't have a good
solution but what I do know
is let's go back to 19
80s late 80s
um American football
there's a quarterback black uh
Douglas Johnson I forgot his Williams
Douglas Williams who black the first
black quarterback to start in our Super
Bowl
articles about this all over the place
okay can a black person is a black
person smart enough to take on such an
important place because the quarterback
calls all the plays not that they really
do today because it comes from the
sidelines but there was all this
articles about it will he succeed in
this place
and it's like I'm thinking what the [__]
okay because I'm getting a PhD in
astrophysics and they're talking about
whether black people are smart enough to
be a quarterback on a football team okay
go back to that time and find those
articles all right so what happens he
sets a a Super Bowl record for the most
number of yards a past received yards
okay end of that conversation and it
ended forevermore now when there's a
black quarterback it doesn't even get
mentioned
that's the content of your character and
not the color of your skin the fact that
you can have that and it doesn't even go
get commented upon
is itself progress here in the United
States I just this morning I did some
morning talk shows okay
they're black reporters there they're
female reporters I remember
people I remember the first woman anchor
and people saying well women are they as
believable as men do they have the
authority do they have the confidence in
their voice this was debated and argued
that why women should not be delivering
the news because we had the voice of
Walter Cronkite and others okay yeah
that was a progressive change and we had
to adapt all right and of course we're
adapting and now we have twice as many
people to choose from to put on to and
we get the best who's out there so you
solve that from the from the base
so so yeah it took decades but yeah it
was a while but I think we're we're
there on many fronts and the fact that
everybody's arguing about trans people
and that argument is not about gay
people
is it self-progress
under President Clinton nobody's talking
about trans people talking about gay
people President Clinton a progressive
president he says oh yeah I have a
progressive idea in the military don't
ask don't tell
so if you were gay you had to withhold
that information from everybody because
if you told them they'd kick you out
that was considered Progressive
today if you say don't ask don't tell
they kick you out of the room what the
[__] what what era did you come up in
so yeah they're baby steps sometimes
but to quote
um
there's a Unitarian minister in the
early 1800s who spoke of the Arc of
progress of Martin Luther King would
quote him in some of his speeches uh the
guy's name is in my book uh he said the
summary of that quote is
um I I don't know how
the Ark of Justice the Ark of the
progress
Benz I know it Ben's but which way has
it been I'm pretty sure it bends towards
uh is it progress
towards progress yeah there's something
like that and that's a variation not
exactly the wording that's in the book
the book has it correct all right and so
so there it is you just hope it doesn't
regress so that we're living
in yesterday's World rather than
Tomorrow's World so that's that's the
this is the only points I'm making here
and yeah let's fix the the Athletics put
more categories in sports figure it out
get the biologists together with the
gender specialist figure it out get the
hormone specialists
it's not unfigure-out-able
no it's been an absolute pleasure thank
you so much for coming on the show and
we spent half the time talking about
gender was it something else we're going
to talk about we didn't actually we
didn't so we are going to go very well
set up Neil you've done a fantastic job
to get people to follow us over to
locals where we will be asking you their
questions before we do though we have
one we want to pay to get to that oh yes
see we're learning from the Americas
this is America baby give me your money
now Francis do the last question for the
main interview yeah okay Neil what's up
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be
I'm guessing it's not trans
are we are we smart enough
to be
proper Shepherds of our own fate yeah
that worries me when I see people making
uninformed or just outright crazy or
stupid decisions related to the health
welfare and safety of our species going
forward sometimes I question whether we
are wise enough
to
uh
you know what it's an old Native
American saying of mangle it but the
sense of it will be there that you want
to behave
such that seven generations from now
they can be proud of you the decisions
you made because we don't be queef it to
them
we
uh How does it go we
we actually inherit the present from our
future Generations
okay they you do a reverse time thing on
it and you ask yourself am I doing the
right thing for them
and I don't sometimes I wonder when I
see the conduct of humans in the world
and it's I'm saddened every now and then
but I'm oh generally an optimist
so then I said when I see where there's
some problems I say maybe I can help
that and put in a little extra
information there so
yeah Neil thank you so much for coming
on Starry Messenger uh really uh
recommend getting the book head on over
to locals and it exists in the UK
there's a UK version of it too oh it's
Sunday Times bestseller actually so yes
was it really okay excellent thank you
it does exist and very successfully so
head on over to locals where we ask Neil
your questions and continue the
conversation
do you have any scientific opinions that
run counter to the scientific consensus
and if so what are they
[Music]